(audience applause)
- Welcome back, I'm
here with my panel.
First up, Nightly Show
contributor Mike Yard,
(audience cheers)
and Nightly Show
contributor Robin Thede,
(audience cheers)
and he's the co-host
of the new music series
Greatest Hits, premiering
next Thursday on ABC,
and you can catch him at
Harrah's Resort in Atlantic City
Saturday July 9th,
legendary TV host, comedian,
and actor Arsenio
Hall, everybody!
(audience applause)
Yes!
That's right.
And for everyone at home
enjoying our conversation
right now on
Twitter @NightlyShow
using the hashtag #Tonightly.
Now, over the
course of two weeks,
Trump really seems to be falling
apart with his candidacy.
I don't know if he is;
But he fired his
campaign manager.
His campaign
virtually has no cash.
His numbers are falling.
I think his unfavorables
like are at 61%
or something like that.
He was lambasted for
his unfavorables,
for his reaction to
the Orlando shootings.
- [Robin] Oh yeah.
- Arsenio, I'm glad you're
here alright, because--
- [Arsenio] I know him.
- [Larry] You have a
personal connection with him.
- I won The Apprentice.
I'm the Jackie
Robinson of Apprentice.
I'm the first.
- So let me ask you, in
your heart of hearts, okay?
- [Larry] Do you think
Donald Trump is truly
invested in becoming president
or is all of this a con?
Is he playing us right now?
- Larry, first of all,
this is Donald Trump
and you know that ego.
He wants to rule the world.
This ain't no game for him.
This ain't no... right?
He wants to rule...
The world
I think he just needs
some black friends.
(audience laughing)
More than Omarosa; I
know what y'all thinking.
- Right.
Yeah, but do you
think... See to me
it seems like when
he started winning,
he was like, "Oh,
shit, I was joking."
(audience laughing)
- Well--
- [Larry] I didn't think
this was gonna happen!
- But Larry, he's got to
win now because he's ruined
his life in every other place.
- [Larry] He has.
- [Arsenio] But
Pennsylvania Avenue.
- [Larry] That is a fact.
- I have a tie that
he gave me once.
It's a Donald Trump tie.
Made in China.
He can't even go to China now.
- [Larry] No he can't.
To even get his own ties.
- Right, right.
He can't go give
orders to the lady.
Nobody's sewing for him
in China ever again.
- [Larry] So nice; I loved it.
- [Mike] I think he's been
trying to get out of it.
- You think he was
actively trying to get out?
- I mean look at the
shit he's been saying.
Does that sound like
somebody that wanna win?
(audience applause)
- [Larry] It's working!
But it's working!
- And I know and he's like us!
I'm sure every time
Trump goes home,
he's like "What the
fuck is going on!?"
- So you think--
- [Mike] I just made fun
of a handicapped dude
and they love me!
- [Larry] I tried
the Mexican joke
and they liked me even more!
- [Robin] I know.
- You know what's crazy
about him hating immigrants?
The Donald Trump I
know, back in the day,
didn't fuck nobody
but immigrants.
- [Robin] Yeah, exactly.
(audience applause)
- [Larry] Back in the day I
believe he was married, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean other
than Marla Maples.
- [Robin] Yeah.
- And she who knows?
I don't even know where she is.
That might be like
Mission: Impossible.
She might do this one day and
it's like, "Oh that's Rosa!"
(audience laughter)
She may not even be white.
The only white woman he
really wants is his daughter.
And you know that.
(audience shock)
- [Robin] Yes, that's my theory!
That's my theory
is that he actually
only ran for president
to impress Ivanka.
I really think so.
- [Larry] Really?
- Yeah he was like--
- [Larry] Wait, he's running
for president to
impress his daughter?
- [Robin] Yes and you know
what no one else talks about?
He has another
daughter that gets
no molesty love?
- That's Marla Maple's
daugther!
- Yeah!
- That's... Yes!
- [Larry] It's so true though.
- [Robin] I don't even want to
have sex with that daughter!
(Robin laughs)
- No molesty love.
- [Robin] No molesty love.
- [Mike] No molesty love.
That's messed up.
- It is messed up.
- [Mike] On so many levels.
- So it that the
art of the deal.
How to get molesty
love is the deal?
- Yeah, chapter 12.
(Larry laughs)
- I did not know that.
- Can I correct something?
I said he needs black friends,
he needs friends period.
Right?
- [Robin] Yeah.
- Because sometimes--
- [Larry] Does he have
any friends?
- [Arsenio] You know...
- Does he really have friends?
Because he used to hang out
with everybody back in the day,
who was something.
- Yeah.
But he wanted to attach himself
to that limelight in that.
But does he really
have any friends?
- If he had friends...
Would his hair be like that?
Right?
(audience laughs)
Right, if he got friends?
Because I'll tell
you something--
- [Larry] Somebody would
of told him by now.
- [Arsenio] Somebody would
pull your coat tails.
If you got a black friend,
they'll pull your coat tails.
I remember one time...
This happened in this town,
we're standing together
and he had a lady pull his hair.
Because she was looking at him;
you know how when
somebody has big breasts
and you keep wandering down
looking at her breasts.
They were looking at his head
just staring at his hair.
Trying to make eye contact,
but kept looking like this...
- It's like my eyes are here.
- Yeah!
(audience laughs)
- Stop looking at my titties.
- My eyes are right here.
- So I pulled him
off to the side,
I didn't want to front
him off in front of people
because he's cool if you
put him off privately
and say, "Yo DT.."
- [Mike] That's what you
called him.
- Yeah!
(Mike laughs)
I mean when you're not
on the air you can say it.
I said on the air
one time; I was like,
"Yo, they don't think
your hair is not real.
"They just think
it's fucked up."
(guests and audience
laughs wildly)
You know?
- I agree, yeah.
- Because he always
had to pull his hair.
- It's not a compliment Donald.
Okay I wanna show you this,
because I want your
reaction to this.
Can we show that
clip of what he said
at his rally when
looking for his
African-American friend?
- Oh!
- My god.
- We gotta show that.
Let's just show that.
- Don't show this clip.
- We had a case where we
had an African-American guy
who was a fan of mine;
Great fan, great guy!
In fact, I wanna find out
what's going on with him.
Oh look at my
African-American over here!
Look at him!
(crowd wooing)
(Robin laughs)
- "My African-American?"
- Yeah, he must of
not got the email;
We free now, you don't own us.
(audience laughs)
You don't own us.
We're free, bruh.
(audience continues laughing)
Enough with you're tripped out
memory lane, motherfucker.
- I love how--
- "My African-American?"
- [Robin] I love how it's just
his game of Where's Waldo,
but just with black people.
I mean his just like--
- [Mike] Like it was hard
to find him at a trump rally.
- Well he was so shocked,
"Oh my god!"
(Robin laughs)
- He knew exactly where he was.
- If he had a black
friend, he wouldn't
of put "my" in that sentence.
- [Robin] Right.
- [Larry] Does he think
you're his black friend?
- Oh not after tonight.
(guests and audience laughs)
- Okay--
- [Arsenio] You know how he
likes to spray his hair
real hard on the sides?
By the way, it's real
crunchy on the sides.
He sprays real hard; but
tonight he's gonna be,
"My nigga, My nigga."
(Robin laughs)
- [Mike] You know that's
what he wanted to say!
- Yeah, that's--
- [Mike] "That's my nigga!"
- [Arsenio] Yeah,
that's what he wanted!
"My nigga, My nigga!"
- They say it, why can't
I say it?
- "My nigga, My nigga!"
- That's exactly what
he wanted to say!
"My African-American."
Shit, come on man.
- You think he's
really serious;
like spending time
with him, you think he's
really really serious?
- He can't go back
to Apprentice, he's
got to be serious.
- [Mike] He can't be. How?
- You don't act a fool
at this job until you
get your next job.
Right?
- Right.
Yeah it's true; It's true.
- He can't go back--
- [Larry] You better make sure
all those lottery
numbers are correct,
or we'll be saying "Fuck
all you motherfuckers...
- Yeah, yeah.
- "I'm out...
"Oh! Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait!
- It's a five;
Wait, it's a five!
- "Wait, wait, wait!
- I thought it was a four!
(Mike claps)
- [Robin] He does need black
and brown votes though.
- [Larry] He can't get black...
Do you think white people
are gonna vote for Trump?
- [Arsenio] No!
- [Mike] Hell no.
- [Larry] You sure?
- [Mike] I don't know;
let me tell you something,
there's no black people voting
for a motherfucker that
labels us "the blacks."
I'm sorry, that's not happening.
- [Arsenio] Yeah.
- You're gonna vote
for a dude that
says "the blacks"?
"The blacks love me."
- Maybe, but he's
a good salesman.
- It's like fucking
with a Borg.
- Let me ask you this.
Okay, here's a challenge;
let me ask you this,
if Trump said "Okay
I am coming out
"for reparations
for black people.
"Hillary's not gonna say this.
"I'm saying reparations
for black people.
"All of you guys, I'm
writing down a $25,000--"
See, you're face is
changing right now!
"I'm writing everybody a
$25,000 dollar check right now,
"and I get to say
nigga, that's right!"
(Robin laughs)
"That's right, I get
"to say nigga; Here's
$25,000 dollars!
"Who's voting for me now?"
- [Mike] For 25 grand, you
don't get to call me nigga.
- [Larry] Are you voting
for him now?
- For 25 grand, you can't
call me nigga; You kidding me?
- [Larry] Okay, he
won't call you that;
Are you voting for him?
- For 25 grand, no.
Nah, not for 25 grand.
- [Arsenio] For me
to vote for him, he's got to do
a Kool-Aid commercial
or something.
Like a strawberry Kool-Aid;
and I'll be like, "I'm
thinking, I'm thinking!"
- [Mike] For me to vote for him,
because you know I'm
the reparations dude,
I've been backing for that show.
- [Larry] So it's
a matter of price?
- Yes, and this is what it is.
If he gave 25 grand and...
like we said earlier, free
college for black people--
- [Larry] That's your price?
- [Mike] It depends though.
I gotta see... Because
I don't trust him.
I gotta see the legislation--
- [Larry] Let me just
say two words.
- [Mike] Because he might
be slick.
- [Larry] Let me just
say two words; Let me
just say two words.
- [Mike] What?
- Sell-out.
Okay, we'll be right back.
(guests and audiences cheers)
We'll be right back.
(Audience cheers)
- [Voiceover] If you live
in the New York city area,
or are planning to visit,
grab some free tickets
to attend an up-coming
taping of The Nightly Show.
Go to TheNightlyShow.com/Tickets